in a remote atoll near tahiti
corey garza andy casagrande and safety
diver perrick seibold
put themselves in the line of fire
these investigators test the theory that
some tiger sharks may work together
and hunt in packs
before they know it they're fending off
a double approach
by two large tiger sharks
and more
again and again
the sharks seem to come in waves
it's too much they must retreat
[Music]
insane moments on that camera
i saw you deflecting one coming here
another one behind you and then at one
point
you and pyrrhic literally like dancing
on tigers
that was crazy you see what i mean now
how they
don't disappear and then as if there's
like one coming it's boom all at once
here we go 360 tiger sharks
they review the footage and search for
clues
if these tigers cooperatively hunt it
may suggest that great whites could also
do the same
oh wow wow
okay one two three three tigers there's
three right there and then another tiger
after careful review corey is convinced
tiger sharks working together makes
sense
it's better for them and easier for them
to learn to cooperate rather than to
spend their whole time
fighting each other it could be an
anomaly unique to this species
except for emerging evidence from around
the world
from sand tiger sharks off south africa
to lemon sharks in australia
and gray reefs in french polynesia
they've all been observed to seemingly
work together
and now this for the tigers of tahiti
this 360 shows us that all of the sharks
in
mass are showing up together and leaving
together
pretty much every single time it's not
and this is not
this isn't coincidence yeah because it's
happening every single time
[Music]
you